nice well done
Jean our little sexy fireman so Jal
Bowman got the sentence of his dreams
while a conservative gets jailed for
memes last week Democrat Congressman
Jamal Bowman pleaded guilty to a
misdemeanor charge for pulling a fire
alarm to delay a vote in the house of
reps I have to say it's nice to see a
Democrat pulling something beside Joe's
finger God new video was released
clearly showing Bowman pulling down
emergency exit signs off the doors and
then pulling the alarm itself this stunt
was so poorly planned it's like he had
help from Jesse
Smet he says that at the time he thought
it would open a door yeah pulling a fire
alarm to open a door just like how you
hope flushing your toilet microwaves of
burrito there was an evacuation for 90
minutes and the capital police had to
lock everything down things hadn't been
that tense in the capital since Jerry
Nadler assumed that he had only farted
why Dem
see as I bring on uh congresswoman
Maloney I want to join package part of
uh preserving our our democracy with
that I'm pleased to yield to the
distinguished chair genuinely going oh
Jerry a classic but as for Bowman well
you know what he did was against DC law
and he's got to take responsibility for
it well you know what I did was against
DC law and so it was against DC law and
I got to take responsibility for it
which I'm here to do uh and looking
forward to just you know taking a deal
paying the fine and then 3 months just
being dismissed and continuing my work
how convenient for Bowman take a deal
pay a fine and in three months it'll all
be dismissed and now like everything bad
that the Dems do the media pretends it
never happened meanwhile a right- Winger
named Douglas McKay was just sentenced
to 7even months for tweeting out Hillary
Clinton memes in 2016 that falsely told
people they could vote by text for her
which is clearly a joke dead people
can't
text years later Hillary's still foaming
at the mouth I guess he was one of the
main people running memes against me in
2016 but he went from that to H running
a very deliberate effort to mislead
people about where and how to vote yeah
so it went from speech to action meant
to subvert the election because
thousands of people who they targeted
through their
algorithms oh I can text my vote for
Hillary Clinton yeah yeah thousands
texted their vote oh yeah because
they're
idiot no offense to Dems and other
people with learning disabilities but if
you're dumb enough to fall for that you
shouldn't be allowed to vote anyway
thank you so this Mackie dude gets hard
time for a meme what feds call election
interference but when Bowman pulls an
alarm and interrupts Congressional
business he gets off with a slap on the
wrist but if a guy gets seven months for
a meme shouldn't Bowman get something
worse no I say give him the
chair a nice leather one so he can sit
and think about the bad things he's
done
Emily what just
happened isn't this crazy a guy in
America goes to jail for a meme seven
months and this guy gets off it's
different rules for different people
it's unfortunate that I feel no surprise
I only feel the same appreciation of the
decay of whatever justice system they're
trying to put in front of our face so he
gets off with a $1,000 fine and he has
to write a letter of apology to the
capital police never minding the
multiple Capital police he walked by
after he pulled the fire alarm and
exited the building that he could have
notified at that moment think about all
the people that are currently rotting in
jail with weirdly no access to any usual
you know civil civil rights things and
la la la uh for January 6th they were
prosecuted under what he should be
prosecuted for which is obstruction of
or interference with a legislative
official proceeding you brought up Jesse
smallet face he was prosecuted for five
felonies that fell under crimes against
the public if filing a false police
report is a felony in so many states and
is considered essentially like a
reduction of the import and and again
that crime against the public it's
called which is that we want to deter it
it is so important that we use police
and EMS appropriately this guy gets
$1,000 fine so they're outside the
building for 90 minutes then I want my
money back I my money paid all of their
salaries where they were on the lawn for
His stunning act so have him pay all of
that back cuz we lost that time as
Citizens this whole thing is such a
farce and to your point the media has
been displaying it and portraying it as
they called it like an odd event or the
like they don't even say no this this
guy would have gotten ripped apart if it
was any one of us yeah you know uh Jimmy
he's going to pay a small fine and write
a letter that's still harsher than DC's
punishment for
carjacking true well I do love that
they're making him write a letter like
he's five like I'm sorry are they going
to set him in the bed with no Xbox too
but it's like it's so dumb but people
saying he should be thrown out of
Congress cuz he lied as not true he
should be thrown at Congress cuz he's
stupid like he did this on camera so he
knew it was going to be proven but this
is what it comes back to he had the
confidence of knowing that as a Democrat
he wasn't going to get prosecuted the
way a republican would you dig so it
isn't you know an exercise and like
Different Strokes for different folks
but that sounds like a sitcom with Biden
and
Federman nicely done Jimmy he also said
you dig you dig Le print jacket I know I
know cat have you ever pulled a fire
alarm to get out of something no um no
you're lawyer say no I was trying to
trick her why did he take the signs down
yeah yeah okay good you got I'm not I'm
not stupid then and then it's guilt yes
I don't know why did he think that like
oh I don't want I don't want people when
they see me pull the fire alarm to think
that like I did I knew I was doing
something bad they going to see you
doing that too also they said he was in
a a rush he's walking so slowly like he
looks more relaxed than I ever have been
in my entire life yeah I know I've never
been that chill totally and also he says
he want he doesn't even look at the door
yeah he's like I thought the fire alarm
would open the door but then he pulls it
and he doesn't even look back once uhhuh
so basically I think he's lying he might
be on
something he looks how relaxed he looks
yeah it looks like he but must have had
a few pops before he went down you know
you you kind of want to give him credit
for the fact that he like like came
clean on it nobody in Washington ever
comes clean on on no no when when he was
uh had to go in and uh and and he he
admitted it that never happens
especially so so he's like the biggest
chump when it comes to like Democrats in
Washington because he comes but this is
but the more important the larger more
serious point is that this is what you
this is sort of the second prong you
have identity politics you divide
Everybody by race and then you apply the
law unequally and when you start to
apply the law unequally this is where
people get to people's throats and this
is where people start uh hating one
another and I I think it's all by Design
I think that this is what politicians in
Washington are looking for they'd rather
have us fight amongst ourselves then
turn our ey towards them so they can
continue with this wasteful war huh and
everything else yeah crazy yeah all
right before we go here's a quick
reminder you can come see me on the next
stop of my book tour yeah it's still
going I'll be in Stamford Connecticut
this Sunday in Albany New York on
December 3rd I love Albany it's the
capital
go to ggutfeld.com for tickets and up
next is KLA ready to replace if Joe's in
a better place hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else